so the easiest way to stop this is to
get vaccinated because fortunately for
us
the vaccine works quite well against it
that is dr fauci talking about the delta
variant a strain of cova 19 that
originated in india now spreading in
some parts across the united states some
health officials are worried
that it could potentially become a super
spreader if more people do not become
vaccinated
kate houston live in our newsroom with
the impact in our area kate
yes brian because the delta variant
spreads so much faster than
others it could quickly become the
dominant strain in the united states
a las vegas doctor tells me we're in a
race against time to get as many people
vaccinated
because that's our main line of defense
against it's spreading further
as of last week the southern nevada
health district has identified
13 cases of the delta variant in clark
county
as covin-19 case positivity rates start
to slightly increase
this is causing concern for local health
officials dr
christina madison with roseman
university tells me this variant poses a
large risk for unvaccinated people
which are 80 percent more likely to be
hospitalized
while around half of eligible people in
clark county have the first dose of the
vaccine
dr madison says that's not enough
especially as
transmission rates rise in the fall as
soon as we get into the colder
weather as soon as we start gathering
more indoors
those things are going to change and if
the delta variant becomes the more
dominant strain here in the united
states
we could see transmission rates two
times as much as we've seen in the past
dr madison says the delta variant can
target all ages
which is why there is a push for
adolescents and young adults to get the
vaccine before heading back to school
the southern nevada health district says
at this time they don't have enough
evidence to show the delta variant
is significantly impacting case counts
in clark county
but as variants spread across the state
and the u.s
they encourage all eligible adults to
get the vaccine back to you brian
all right kate thank you for that now
the average number of daily cases being
reported in clark county
still down overall but slightly taking
up as of late we are averaging
165 new cases that is up about 30 cases
per day
from the low of 132 on june 5th in our
state of 3.1 million
here